[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
bible the word of god
welcome to bible answers live providing
accurate and practical answers to all
your bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
bible related question give us a call
now at 800 god says that's 800-463-7297
pastor doug batchelor
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
in 2015 guinness world records
identified maasanram india as the
wettest place on earth
the region about 4 600 feet above sea
level receives rainfall of
449 inches annually that's almost 40
feet of rain a year more than three
times as much as hilo hawaii which is
the wettest place in the 50s united
states
and that's just their average in 1985
the region experienced a record busting
1 000 inches of rain
the area is blessed with incredible
flora and fauna but you better bring
your umbrella year round the torrential
rains are caused by warm moist winds
carried from the bay of bengal that are
funneled into a narrow zone of cool air
over the kashi hills
thus continually transforming the
moisture into mist and rain clouds
and it doesn't just rain it pours any
house with a tin roof becomes so loud
it's virtually impossible to have a
conversation
many homes and schools use grass roots
to quiet the roar when it rains in a
heavy way
during the monsoon season it's not
uncommon to have 40 days of unrelenting
rain in masanrom
fortunately the land is steep and well
drained so it never floods i even heard
pastor ross they actually have trouble
getting drinking water
because it rains so much and it all just
runs down the hill they've not been able
to build a containing pond what do they
say water water everywhere and not a
drop to drink right
well you know pastor we're just talking
about it here you have a place that has
so much water so much rain and then you
have other places on the planet that is
just uh dying for rain i mean i think
california and the western part of the
united states it's been dry and of
course you have fires as a result
and yet there's some places that just
have a lot of rain of course you've been
in a while i have we've been in hilo
and
it does rain there a lot almost every
day when i was there it rained it's very
common the afternoon the clouds gather
and and it rains and
i was there once on vacation with our
family what didn't you know it was a
vacation
and hawaii had experienced 40 days and
40 nights of rain it wasn't continual
but for 40 days it rained
which makes us think of what story in
the bible whenever you talk about 40
days of rain you think of noah and the
flood now of course fortunately
we're not going to have a worldwide
flood but yes our 40 days of rain you
think of noah
um but noah is also used in the bible
not only connected with rain passado but
he's also used with sort of our time and
things that are taking place just before
jesus comes yeah the lord said that as
it was in the days of noah the
conditions that brought on the
destruction of the world back then will
be replicated and the bible tells us
that you know violence filled the world
at that time of course we've got you
know war and violence on the streets and
then
and uh in on the battlefront
as well as immorality
and jesus said the days would be like
the days of noah and the days of lot
meaning sodom and gomorrah
and that kind of describes conditions in
the world today you can read this in
luke 17 26
jesus is speaking he said
as it was in the days of noah so will it
be also in the days of the son of man
they ate and they drank they married
wives they were given in marriage not
that there's anything wrong with eating
and drinking he's talking about to
excess
um
mary and wives giving in marriage
marriage and divorce it's talking about
until the day that noah entered the ark
and the flood came and destroyed them
all
so and they did not know both in
in in sodom and gomorrah in the among
the people living in noah's day
the sun was shining for seven days
before the flood
and
then boom it happened and jesus tells us
one of the shortest verses in the bible
he says speaking of the last days
remember lot's wife
the people then didn't know it was their
last night their last day and we've got
an offer that i think talks about that
the book is called the last night on
earth and it looks at these prophecies
in the bible they talk about end time
events we'll send it to anyone for free
all you have to do is call the number
6747 you can ask for offer number 101 or
ask by name the book is called the last
night on earth we'll be happy to send it
to anyone in north america again that
number is 800-835-6744
seven that is our resource phone line
this is a live program and if you have a
bible question the phone line here to
the studio is 800-463-7297
that's
800-463-7297 pastor doug we were just
talking before the program we mentioned
we haven't had a chance to actually do a
live program sort of on and off for a
couple of weeks but it's good to be back
and finally we're able to take these
bible questions as sort of a amen
bible study so if you have a bible
related question frame call 800-463-7297
well before we go to the phone lines you
always like to start with the word of
prayer so we'll do that now
dear father we thank you for your word
the bible we thank you for the
opportunity to be able to study together
and lord we ask your blessing upon this
program and also those who are listening
wherever they might be
lead us into a clearer and a full
understanding of the bible we ask this
in jesus name amen amen
all right we're going to go to the phone
lines our first call of this evening is
glenn listening in
in ohio glenn welcome to the program
good evening
thank you very much for taking my call
yes and it concerns the question of a
translation of the bible which means
much to me and i think it's a
it's a significant mistranslation it's
first john 5 18
there's two sections to the verse
in king james it says he who is born of
god does not sin
but i heard a translation the other day
on radio 74
it said he that abideth with god does
not sin
and
that i think that it's diluting the
truth and that's you know when one is
born again
and uh i i i this question that my
question is you know the validity of
that myth that translation
yeah well there's of course several
translations translate this differently
i typically read the king james the new
king james i just you got me curious and
i opened up the english standard version
and here it reads we know that everyone
who has been born of god does not keep
on sinning
but he who is born of god but is
protects him and the evil one does not
touch him
and so i think when i've looked at this
first before and pastor ross maine also
know about it
the verb that is used there for sin is
talking about practicing sin so when
we're born again we do not live a life
of practicing sin it doesn't mean that
if a person is born again that they are
incapable of sin or they may not stumble
and fall
so
is it does that make sense
you have a second part of that that says
that he that is begotten
of god keepeth himself that the evil
won't touch him not and it doesn't sound
like there's that much difference
between the first part and the second
part if you say if you relate the first
part to does not continue to sin
and being born of god to me is the
ultimate
and i understand that some people even
go so far as to translate that he who is
born of god cannot sin
and
that sounds like that would be the truth
of the matter once you're born of god
there's no sin to be done it makes a lot
of sense to me and when i heard that it
kind of deluded that truth about when
one is born again
yeah well i'm in the king james we know
that whoever is born of god sinneth not
but he that is begotten of god keeps
himself that the wicked one touches him
not and i think that's just telling us
that uh when a person is born again they
do not live a life of sin but again i
don't think you can use this first to
say that once a person is born again
they are sinless from then until their
death or jesus returns
so is that what you're wondering are you
saying that
well i think that the thing that's
deluded is
my personally i believe that a person is
saved and born again like yeshua was and
that's by a resurrection and that's
going to be at the second coming and
from that point forward we're eternally
secure and there's no more no when
you're born of god there's no more sin
there that that's my thinking
okay
yeah i mean you're the point you're
mentioning they're talking about the
resurrection i think we're all in
agreement there that when jesus comes
and the dead in christ are resurrected
absolutely sin is no more eventually
there is the final destruction of sin
and sinners
but we can be spiritually born again now
we can be
set free jesus said if the son sets you
free you shall be free indeed it's right
but once again the bible also warns us
that says let him who thinks he stands
takes heed lest he fall so you know
peter said lord i'm ready to go to
prison and to death and then we find out
a little later in the same chapter he
denies christ so we can never be
self-conscious and think somehow we can
overcome in our own strength it is
christ that works in us right so we've
got to keep trusting in him
we have a book that i think would uh
answer this it gives a really balanced
view and it's got a provocative title is
it possible to live without sinning
and joe cruz the author of this booklet
he goes through the scriptures and talks
about what it means to live a holy life
and he deals with the subject of
sinlessness as well so folks would
really enjoy that it's the book called
is it possible to live without sinning
if you'd like to receive the book all
you need to do is call the number
800-835-6747
and you can ask for the book is that
possible to live without sinning we'll
be able to send that to anyone in north
america if you're outside of north
america you'd like to read the book just
go to the amazing facts website
amazingfacts.org
and you can read it on our free uh
library there on our website thanks for
call glenn we've got brittany listening
in california brittany welcome to the
program
hey
hi thanks for calling
and your question
yeah my question is
what is the name ralchus only and only
in john's gospel and not in the others
are you talking about when uh jesus was
arrested and peter
and peter cut off the ear of malcus
yeah talking about that
my guess is when you read the gospel of
john john seems to have more personal
information on what's happening
with the court and the trial because
you'll read that the other disciples
forsook christ and fled peter he stayed
outside with the
the servants of the high priest john
knew somebody that was uh related to the
high priest he went in he saw these
things firsthand he gives a little more
information about what was the name of
the servant that had his ear whacked off
but uh that that's my understanding
i think he's just adding some additional
details there as to who this person was
you want to pass it out the bible
doesn't tell us but you wanted to have
your ear cut off and then healed
miraculously by jesus
or did this malcus ever become a
believer i don't know you know the bible
does say that there were priests that
eventually became believers after christ
rose from the dead through the preaching
of the apostles so we don't know if this
were malcus a servant of one of the
priests the high priest servant uh the
bible doesn't say his name i just looked
it up out of curiosity the name malcus
means the counselor
it means a reigning counselor
interesting
all right well thanks you're cool
brittany we've got caleb listening in
new york caleb welcome to the program
hello thank you pastor ross and pastor
ambassador doug
thank you for picking up my call
thanks for calling so my question my
question is i had a dream the other
night that really scares me
i'm um i wonder if does god speak
different dreams because as you know the
return of christ is describing the bible
as a um a wedding and we are the the
church of the bridegroom
and the other night had his dream and my
brother i have a brother who is not
really
religious he doesn't really go to church
which which is that's i'm not judging
him you know i'm not i'm no better than
him
but um i had a dream was supposed to go
wedding
and he made it there and i was late i
was running late
and i've been nervous and
about this and i was running late and i
didn't the dream ended like i don't know
if i made it
i was just wondering is that like a sign
of god telling me
you know get my life together or is it
something i may not make it to heaven
does god do that would he do that
would he warn me
well he you know
let me give you a scripture of course
i'm not going to claim i've got the the
gift of interpretation
but it does tell us in the book of joel
chapter 2 and you look at verse 28
and it'll come to pass afterward that i
will pour out my spirit on all flesh and
your sons and your daughters will
prophesy your old men will dream dreams
and your young men will see visions
so
having dreams or god giving dreams
there's nothing in the bible that tells
us that god has ever
curtailed that ability to speak to
people through dreams
i mean he spoke to joseph through a
dream god even spoke to pontius pilate
through a dream and said you know his
wife his wife rather and pilate's wife
was told have nothing to do with that
just man
so and she wasn't a christian
so god can certainly speak
to you through dreams and maybe the lord
is telling you that
yeah i don't think god would give you a
dream just to tell you you're doomed he
probably would give you a dream to tell
you that
you know this could be your fate if you
don't repent and come back to him
what but i'm not like i said i'm not
going to pretend i'm daniel or joseph
and i understand what that dream means
that be between you and the lord but yes
the bible says god does speak through
dreams
and there's different times in our life
probably that we can look back and we
can see how god was speaking to us maybe
through a friend maybe through
circumstances maybe through a dream
or an impression and it's god wanting to
get our attention trying to warn us
saying you know you're doing something
wrong or repent or this is the way i
want you to go
so i think we need to be sensitive to
that of course we've got to test
everything by the word of god i mean you
don't have a dream and then
if it contradicts the bible say well
this must be god no god will never
contradict the bible but we do want to
be sensitive to that yeah i've heard a
number of testimonies in recent years
and this you know this is not what you
base your theology on of
people like for instance in islam and
someone will have a dream and the lord
speaks to him and says
jesus appears to them and they had no
inclination they weren't reading the
bible and he says i am the truth read
the bible
and
they say god gave me a dream and it
brings them to the lord it's hard to
question that i mean it seems like it's
valid
so all right well thanks for your call
caleb uh again friends if you have a
bible question the phone line is
800-463-7290
that'll get you right here in the studio
800-463-7297
we've got arien aaron listening in north
dakota aaron welcome to the program
thank you thank you for calling
the quick question in matthew 24
it says and pray that your flight may
not be in winter or on the sabbath
it's obvious that you don't want to be
running in the winter
but why would you not want to run on the
sabbath
well uh for one thing you know the
sabbath is supposed to be a day of rest
you wouldn't want it to be a day of
anxiety and fleeing for your life so it
would sort of be the antithesis of the
purpose of the sabbath
uh you don't want to be in a situation
where you're challenged with that kind
of decision you know
uh soldiers are ready to go to war but
in israel they they really don't like
going to war on sabbath but they will if
they have to
um and so and i've heard people say that
this is a dual prophecy because
sometimes on sabbath it talks about
nehemiah they threatened to shut the
gates on sabbath because the people were
going out and buying and selling i don't
think that's the best argument for this
verse because jesus is looking down in
history
hundreds if not thousands of years
so
i think mainly he's just saying
you know fleeing for your life is not uh
a good restful practice
and in the immediate context of the
verse was talking about the destruction
of jerusalem where the romans surrounded
the city
and the idea that the gate would be open
during the week and then closed on the
sabbath
well that doesn't really make sense if
the enemy is outside the walls the gate
would have been closed all the time so
this wasn't just to
an admonition that pray that you don't
have to flee on the sabbath because the
gate would be closed but rather the idea
is if you're going to be keeping the
sabbath which the disciples of christ
and the christians were to be doing and
this is some 70 a.d yeah it means that
the sabbath was still a special day
especially of worship and communion and
so it has relevance and importance right
and not in the winter because there's no
food in the fields to clean or harvest
and according to history pastor i don't
believe the christian the christians who
recognize that sign and listen to the
words of jesus when it came time for
them to flee from jerusalem history
bears fact that they didn't have to flee
in winter neither on the sabbath so
their prayers were answered god took
care of them next quarter that we have
is juan listening from massachusetts
juan welcome to the program
hi thank you guys um first i want to say
i'm a big fan of pastor uh bachelor and
uh you ross and i pray that god keeps
blessing you both
thank
you um so my question is um is it
possible in today's day and age
to be translated into heaven
before jesus comes like enoch and elijah
did
well the bible says all things are
possible with god
uh you know that would certainly be the
exception uh the rule is it's appointed
unto man wants to die in the judgment
unless you're alive when the lord
returns
you know someone might be caught up in
vision
it just as you know john was and the
prophets may be shown a vision of heaven
but to literally be taken up like enoch
i don't anticipate that's going to
happen very much in the last days
especially now because people would
assume that the secret rapture had taken
place
and only one person was ready
so
anyway any thoughts on that yeah i'm
just going to add to that it's
significant that elijah was taken to
heaven and that moses who died and was
resurrected was taken to heaven and they
served as types for the second coming
when christ comes again you'll have
those will be translated without seeing
death symbolized by elijah and you have
those who are resurrected symbolized by
moses and enoch it says he was the
seventh from adam and eve he's like the
last generation right he's resurrected
so there are all three types
yeah there's significance too so god
doesn't really need the types anymore so
probably not yeah i mean i think we're
close enough to the end of time now they
say wait for the real just wait yeah
we're almost there
all right thank you for your call juan
we've got phil listening in arizona phil
welcome to the program
thank you thank you um just want to
thank both of you guys for your program
you present it's been so helpful for me
my question is um
the quotes are speaking in tongues um
i've been told that it's
evidence that you have the holy spirit
and it's something that um
it's needed i guess it's proof of the
holy spirit i've heard people that were
speaking in tongues but you know i
couldn't understand what they're saying
and there was no one there pretty much a
kind of interpreter to what's going on
i thought it was more along the lines i
read in acts that
there was a myriad of people there at
the time of speaking different languages
and they were to talk to all of them in
their native tongue so if you can
explain that to me i appreciate it
yeah speaking in tongues is a gift of
the spirit that is often misunderstood
it's to make it very simple
jesus told the apostles and you'll read
this in mark chapter 16 he said you will
speak with other tongues
the holy spirit would come on them and
one of the signs would be they would
speak with other tongues
what does that mean
well they were bright
but not formally educated
and very few of them spoke other
languages they all probably spoke
aramaic maybe a little bit of latin and
greek because they were occupied by
those two
forces
but on the day of pentecost the lord
miraculously gave the apostles and those
in the upper room
the ability to speak in other
foreign tongues meaning tongues of
people in the world
that they had not formally studied or
known because they were visiting jews
from every nation under heaven this is
acts chapter 2 in jerusalem worshiping
on pentecost they heard the disciples
speaking in their tongues from the
countries where they had come
and they accepted jesus and then took
the gospel back with them to these other
countries so it was a brilliant way to
spread the gospel they didn't have time
to go through a a cram course in foreign
languages the holy spirit gave them this
ability
and when you read in first corinthians
it makes an emphasis there that we're
really not to be speaking unless people
understand what we're saying
and paul said i'd rather say five words
with my understanding that i might
instruct others in a ten thousand an
unknown tongue
and he says if the trumpet makes an
uncertain sound who will prepare for the
battle and if you're going to speak in a
different language make sure that it's
translated
and you may need two translators and
he's talking to the corinthian church
where there were multiple language
groups there
and the services had become very
confusing and so paul only addresses
speaking in tongues here in first
corinthians
um peter never talks about it um
john never talks about it matthew never
talks about it luke never other than
acts chapter 2. luke doesn't talk about
it i guess acts
10 and acts 19 tell of a case where they
spoke in tongues but there are other
language groups present
so
the fruit of the spirit is not tongues
the evidence of the spirit are the gifts
of the spirit
love joy jesus said you'll know them not
by the fruits but by the gifts
love joy peace galatians chapter 5 is
where you find the gifts of the spirit
that's the evidence for the holy spirit
and if you think of the word tongue just
think of the word language and the
purpose of a language is to communicate
and in this case it's communicating the
gospel right and it was demonstrated in
the beautiful way there on pentecost we
had representatives from the whole realm
they heard them preach the gospel in
their own language they were able to
take it back and share it
and pastor
are there still needs today for the same
gift the gift of tongues is that still
relevant or does god not give the gift
of tongues anymore or does he give it in
a different way
yeah well sometimes i think people get
the gift of tongues in a practical sense
in that they've got
a natural ability for languages and
they're blessed with the ability to
translate and speak
i saw some people in church just
yesterday that
they spoke like four languages and it's
always very impressive to me
when people are have that gift
i did an amazing fact one time about a
man that spoke about a hundred languages
wow
they just picked it up they never had a
photographic memory anyway we have a
book on that that talks about the gift
of tongues and it's called understanding
tongues we'll send you a free copy then
i'm going to call for that is 800
463 actually 800 835 is the number uh
6747 800 835
that is our resource phone line you can
ask for the book it's called
understanding tongues and we'll be happy
to send this out to anyone who calls and
asks again that number is 800-835-6747
and as we've said before if you're
outside of north america we're unable to
send you the book but you can go to the
amazing facts website you can actually
read the book they're online and i
believe pastor like you've got a sermon
dealing with the subject of speaking in
tongues what does the bible have to say
about that and that's available even if
one were to go to youtube and just type
in doug batchelor speaking in tongues
and i think probably something like that
it'll come up it's amazing to me how
google works i know how to find the
stuff yeah absolutely looking at the
fall at the time pastor today we
probably don't have time to take another
call before we take our mid program
break
but just a few things to kind of let our
listeners know about there's a lot
happening here at the amazing facts
ministry
and uh we just finished up a weekend
dealing with a special summit that we
did right here at amazing facts
focused on the youth and the power of
the story and i believe all of those
programs are archived
again at youtube or at the granite bay
facebook page if anyone missed any of
those presentations they can actually go
and take a look at it it was a blessing
we had people come from across the
country
and just a very powerful weekend yeah it
was really nice we had some great
speakers there and i think that we've
got a new website that's developing it's
afyouth.com
and that's af meaning amazing facts
youth and so we'll have
more resources that will be growing for
young people this sort of grew out of
the pandemic we had international youth
bible study
and it kept growing and last year we had
our first youth conference and the
church was full and it was full again
last
yesterday and last night for yes this
program so yeah just go take a look at
those programs you'll find them at you
can actually go to the granite bay
hilltop website i know they're archived
there and they are probably also
archived on
youtube as well and eventually they will
be on the amazing facts website on that
youth amazing faculty website i think
they're busy editing some of the
programs and they'll actually be
available there so folks can take a look
at it and they will be blessed just a
great variety of speakers and wonderful
topics yep amen now we are going to come
back in just a moment with more bible
questions don't forget this is not
something you can only listen to we know
people are listening on land-based or
satellite radio across the country but
you can also watch
the programs are airing not only on
the amazing facts television station af
tv but you can also see it on the
amazing facts facebook page you can join
us here in the studio also on the doug
batchelor facebook page
and we'll be back in just a few minutes
take some more bible questions
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
would you like to know god's plan for
our troubled world and solutions for
your life's challenges beautifully
redesigned and updated amazing facts 27
bible study guides provide
straightforward bible-based answers that
are enlightening encouraging and easy to
understand giving you real relevant
bible answers to questions like how can
i have healthier relationships when will
jesus come and much more order yours
today by visiting afbookstore.com
or by calling 800-538-72
every year 40 000 souls in north america
end their own lives
suicide is a terrible tragedy and while
it's difficult to talk about we need to
face it together as christians
that's why in my new book choosing life
i share the biblical perspective about
suicide answering some difficult
questions about faith and salvation
along the way
and offering practical tips that should
help and encourage others jesus wants us
to choose an abundant life in him
are you looking for a simple way to
share your faith
if you've ever found yourself
tongue-tied when trying to explain what
the bible teaches about the sabbath the
second coming or the afterlife
you'll love the new amazing facts tracts
these colorful tracks feature easy to
read type and are large enough to grab
everyone's attention but small enough to
fit in your pocket to carry with you
wherever you go
eleven key bible teachings are available
now purchase a sample bundle to see what
fits your needs then buy them in bulk
and save
equip yourself and your church to reach
your community with the eye-catching
amazing facts tracks
easy to read easy to share
to order your sample bundle call
800-538-7275
or visit afbookstore.com
and get ready to share your faith like
never before
you're listening to bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of god and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the bible
or living the christian life call us now
at
god says that's 800-463-7297
now let's rejoin our hosts for more
bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to bible
answers live if you've joined us along
the way this is a live international
interactive bible study and you are
invited to call in with your bible
questions and pastor ross we've got
several lines open now yeah we took a
couple weeks off because we were
traveling i was in ireland for two weeks
and send greetings to the people there
we even have people there that watch the
programs it's usually archived but they
watch the programs over there in ireland
and
so you know when you do a couple reruns
and people think you're not really alive
anymore but we are live so if you have a
bible question call us tonight that
number 800 god says or 800-463-7297
is the same number i am doug batchelor
my name is john ross and as you
mentioned yesterday we're not only uh on
the radio
we can also
you can also tune in through facebook
through youtube we're also on the
amazing facts television uh network or
channel so many ways that a person can
participate in this live international
bible study all right phone number again
is 800-463-7297
that'll bring you here into the studio
with your bible question next caller
that we have is joe listening in
colorado joe welcome to the program
hello pastors thank you so much for
taking my call yes sir
yeah so my question uh refers to uh
proverbs chapter 8 uh verse 22
to 31 um
i'll start here it says the lord
possessed me in the beginning of his way
before his works of old
i was set up from everlasting from the
beginning
or ever the earth was so i
understand jesus is lord
and this is
lord speaking right here
so who did the lord possess that i just
i'm having trouble understanding that
passage do not be troubled jesus said
let not your heart be troubled john
chapter 14. let's go back to the first
verse in chapter eight
and here solomon this is a whole
soliloquy about wisdom and what you're
reading is part of this
notice it says does not wisdom cry out
and understanding left up her voice
she takes her stand on the high hill he
goes through and he compares wisdom to
several things he compares wisdom to a
woman he compares wisdom to his son
and so the whole passage is talking
about wisdom this is not talking about
god creating jesus
it's just talking about the attributes
my fruit you look at verse 19 is better
than gold yes fine gold and revenue of
choice silver the lord possessed me in
the beginning of his way now i'm in
verse 22. talking about wisdom before
his works of old i've been established
from everlasting from the beginning
this is all about wisdom and people
sometimes just read these verses and
they don't realize that this is a whole
passage
talking about
how valuable wisdom is
of course coming from solomon the wisest
king that would be appropriate
does that make sense
yes it makes a whole yeah it makes a lot
of sense thank you all right hey thank
you so much
next quarter that we have is steve
listening from missouri steve welcome to
the program
steve might be muted
because he's been holding patiently
steve are you there uh yes i am can you
hear me we do now
yes thank you pastors
my question is i'm kind of confused
about the city of david uh in the old
testament it seems like it was jerusalem
when he over
when he conquered jerusalem
it said it became the city of david and
then when we go to luke i think is when
the angels are talking to the shepherds
it says
uh your savior is born in the city of
david and then that's bethlehem so can
you clear that up for me
yeah you've asked a good question that
i've had myself yeah i wish i could say
that i
know all the answers but i've noticed
that also sometimes it refers to as
jerusalem as the city of david sometimes
one time or a couple times it talks
about david being of course born in
bethlehem jesus born in the city of
david meaning where david was born
david wanted his capital to be in
jerusalem and then keep in mind
bethlehem is not far from jerusalem so
the phrase city of david is used for
both cities that's the only way i can
answer that and just to add to that i
think the phrase city of david with
reference to jerusalem was a temporary
name because it was conquered the old
jebusite fortress conquered by david
named it the city of david but it didn't
take long before it became known as
jerusalem and then once it was sort of
adopted as jerusalem
rarely does is it referred to as the
city of david anymore it served as
jerusalem especially when the temple was
built there as the dwelling place of god
so the city of david from that time
onwards seems to be more related to
bethlehem the birthplace of david than
actually jerusalem because jerusalem
replaced the city of david so to speak
so hopefully that made sense yeah what's
that where was david buried they buried
all the kings in the city of david i
thought they said that too yeah david is
buried in jerusalem
in jerusalem okay so they do refer to it
even after the death of david sometimes
they referred to uh jerusalem as the
city of david because it was the city he
chose
uh as the capital and where he chose to
build the temple that was the love of
his heart is to have a temple for god's
glory so i've just i've studied this and
i've just seen it's interchangeable is
the only thing that i can come up with
sometimes it's talking about the city
where david was born
and calling bethlehem a cities back in
david's day was sort of funny because it
was like a little pueblo it wasn't very
big
and then
later he moved the capital to jerusalem
and that was called the city of david
but they're not far from each other
either and wasn't the city of david a
portion of jerusalem wasn't the whole
temple mount it was the original
jebusite yeah we went and looked at it
yeah i remember in jerusalem there was
one area that referred to as more the
city of david because he had
the jebusite city yeah interesting all
right thanks your call steve we've got
becky listening from michigan vicki
welcome to the program
hello how you guys doing
doing well how can we help you tonight
um question is i'm i'm struggling with a
diet i'm trying to lose weight to stay
healthy and i'm really struggling with
it i'm going by a bible scripture in
philippians chapter 4 verse 13.
i could do all things through christ who
strengthens me
maybe i can get get some advice from you
guys
yeah you know it it is a struggle and
especially
uh any habit
uh and you know changing your habits of
eating
as with any habit
um it's like you're trying to crawl out
of a rut that you've been in
now keep in mind every time that you say
no to the temptation to eat either
something or time or an amount you
shouldn't be eating which is usually
that covers every aspect of a diet
you make it easier next time let me see
if i can put it this way for you and
that might help you
you have been walking down a trail a
particular trail for years
and you've gotten used to it and it's
cleared and it's easy but it's the
trails going the wrong way
now you've got to
plow a new trail
but there's thorn bushes and things that
are blocking the trail the first time
you go through you gotta hack your way
through and you're tripping and it's a
real problem but you know what the next
time you take that trail
you did plow things down a little bit it
gets a little easier and the next time
it gets a little easier and every time
you say no to temptation and you say yes
to the right thing
it makes it easier the next time
so
one way that we overcome through the
power of god is one moment at a time
it's day by day sometimes hour by hour
for me and i often refer back to this
one of my biggest struggles was
smoking
and this say sometimes quitting smoking
is as hard as heroin
and i struggled and boy the first few
days i'd quit smoking i'd think about it
just every few minutes that's i couldn't
get it out of my mind i could barely
make it from hour to hour
and i felt several times
but finally i quit and said enough's
enough and i made it you know a day then
two then three and now it's been 40
years so you can do it and
i have a video
i think pastor ross heard it
i actually had a food addiction
and i shared this video of
how i overcame my addiction all i'm
going to do is tell you the title of it
it's a doug batchelor cold confession
if you want to take a listen to that
becky just go to youtube type in doug
batchelor cold confession
and i'll tell you kind of i'll you'll
hear me confess what my addiction was
and uh how the lord helped me get the
victory
and praise god he's helped me keep the
victory for about now eight years now
anyway
absolutely it's a great sermon really
encouraging for a lot of people i
remember today when you actually
got up and preached that sermon you
could hear a pin drop in the
congregation at least at first when you
said i'm going to make a confession
people want to hear the minister confess
they don't know what to say but it was
extremely encouraging and yeah just a
great blessing and uh take a look at
that if you haven't becky i think you'll
be blessed if you have a bible question
friends we've got uh oh about 15 16
minutes left and if i you have a
question that you're wondering about the
bible or the christian life the number
to call is 800-463-7297
that's 800-463-7297
hello hi how are you
you're on i'm good
i have a i have a question uh
i i don't really know if it counts much
as a
christian question in general but it's
more about just
kind of like what it is like once we get
to heaven
but uh okay
fire away
all right uh my question is about the
amount of free will we have in heaven i
was always confused like growing up
in in the church where
we were we were told that we had like
free will to like do pretty much
anything we wanted and
yet it was in always in the boundaries
of what was good and right and moral
which is something that humanity in
general was just not
always good at
right say the least
i i was wondering if like once we reach
heaven are we
beyond the reality of sin completely or
are we just absolved from it continually
but
we'll know that you know it's a good
question i think i understand what
you're saying will we still be free
moral agents in heaven or since we're
beyond the possibility of being tempted
does that mean we're no longer free
um you know i might answer that
and hopefully i'm i'm rightly restating
your question but
i might answer that by saying um
you there is a law that says you're not
supposed to murder your children
most people don't think very much about
that law because most people don't want
to murder their children it's kind of a
very bizarre perversion when
it's you know one in a million
parents that would think such a thing
because most parents they love their
children it's the last thing that would
ever come into their mind now they're
free to murder their children
if you wanted to i mean you know what
i'm saying
they've got the ability
but um
they don't think about it because they
love their children in heaven we'll
still have that freedom to sin
but now we are so full of the love of
god and love for one another that when
you look at the ten commandments we are
keeping them now because we love
and so are we still free more moral
agents yes you can read in the book of
name that sin will not rise up the
second time jesus when he rose from the
dead he still had the scars from his
crucifixion in his hands that will be a
perpetual reminder of what sin cost and
we won't want to ever sin again not to
mention the devil is gone
absolutely and you know again you can't
have true love without freedom right and
the whole experiment with sin proves
that
the devil will take worship anywhere he
can get it but god can only accept
worship that he's freely given well
that's true for the rest of eternity god
still will accept worship freely given
of course we won't want to not worship
him because we've seen what sin can do
yeah and we'll love it it'll be our
greatest joy yep absolutely good
question thank you taylor we've got uh
sean listening from oklahoma sean
welcome to the program
hey guys what's going on
well we're living day by day with the
lord how are you doing it's really good
to talk to you guys doug you pretty much
saved my life
well the lord did it but i'm glad if i
could be involved praise god i know
that's right but i just want to say
thank you from the bottom of my heart
guys i watched amazing facts and i
follow you guys and listen to youtube
all the time
well praise the lord i wish everyone was
listening to our programs on youtube but
i know they're watching other stuff
i'm on i'm on my knees every night
praying that your message goes a little
bit more around the world than it
already is oh that means a lot we
appreciate that thank you
all right um my question is uh i know
it's called the millennial reign and
it's millennial means uh like thousand
years but is there anything going to
happen after that
yeah well we will offer you a lesson on
that in just a minute but um at the
conclusion of the one thousand years and
for our friends that are listening you
find the verses on the one thousand
years sometimes called the millennium
the word millennium is mili anima it
just means thousand years you'll find
that in revelation chapter 20.
and you can find illusions to the
thousand years in a few other places in
the bible but most of it's there in
revelation 20. and it tells us that the
devil is tied up for a thousand years
and at after the thousand years he is
loosed for a little season and it says
the rest of the dead don't live again
till the thousand years are finished so
at the end of the 1000 years the rest of
the dead live again that's all the lost
dead in christ rise first if all the
dead in christ rise first the only dead
that are left are the dead out of christ
or the lost the wicked
they're resurrected and
satan is now loose because he has
someone to tempt
the bible refers to this mass of all the
lost who've ever lived in the
resurrection of the the lost
is uh or the second resurrection as gog
and magog
those are ancient enemies of god's
people
and the devil will
stir them to launch an assault on the
city of god so they say surround the
beloved city the camp of the saints and
fire comes down from god out of heaven
and devours them now you'll also find
that uh
that passage in revelation 20 is also
taken from ezekiel 37 and 38
talks about gaga magog they surround my
people like a cloud very same words that
you're going to find in revelation and
then god fights for his people
then um god is going to create a new
heavens and a new earth following that
so
it's a it's a very interesting time now
we have a lesson that talks about that
thousand years of peace is that still
the title it is it's called a thousand
years a piece it's one of our amazing
facts study guides gets into quite a bit
of detail about what happens uh during
that thousand years what will happen at
the end of the thousand years to receive
it all you have to do is call the number
800-835-6747
that is our resource phone line
800-835-6747 ask for the study guide
it's called a thousand years of peace
and we'll be happy to send that to
anyone who calls and asks
and a great study really exciting such
uh subject so thanks for call sean we've
got
milo listening from rhode island milo
welcome to the program
homilo hey hey you hear me yeah
hey how are you
doing great
how can we help you tonight
so um just been recently saved um you
can say i've been saved for about four
to five months you could say yeah five
congratulations praise god appreciate it
amen amen and i'm so grateful and um i
have this desire to you know
minister and disciple and just to assist
god as much as possible but i don't know
where to go whether north south east or
west or who to talk to
and um
i just don't even know how to even jump
start quote unquote my christian career
so to say so how do i
you know find my purpose and my will
of god
well i know exactly how you feel well i
think i do but i was in the same boat
after i came to the lord i instead you
know i was living in a cave i wanted to
get away from people and i came to the
lord now i wanted to tell everybody
and
i was just i'd say lord you know what do
you want me to do
now
i wanted things to happen right away
and god wanted me to take some more time
to study and get grounded and so things
did not happen right away but god
certainly did guide he did open the
doors keep in mind moses said lord i'm
ready for you to use me i'm ready to
lead the people out of egypt and he's a
matter of fact
before god told him he thought he'd do
it on his own and
he killed an egyptian and thought he'd
get everybody to rally behind him and
next thing he knew he was out in the
wilderness for a few years
so
paul after he was converted he went to
arabia for a couple of years anyway yeah
and he was studying there and getting
grounded and then he was very effective
your next step may be going to school
you might even consider the amazing
facts afco program
the lord just told me to say that or to
do that yeah absolutely you know i would
encourage anyone listening who wants to
be of service begin by by really
grounding yourself in the practical
truths of the bible amazing facts
there's a free course we call it the uh
the bible school
and uh that's a great starting point for
anyone wanting to learn what does the
bible have to say on a number of
important topics
once you learn and you discover these
truths and you're able to learn them for
yourself then you're in a position to
share them with somebody else so milo if
you go to the website that says bible
universe
if you go to bibleuniverse.com there's a
series of bible studies you can go
through there for free and that will
really ground you i also have a book
we'll send you for free and it's called
how do i know the will of god or
determining the will of god
and it'll give you steps to know god's
will for you and i think it'll give you
peace that if you follow those steps
he will he'll be guiding you even if
part of that means waiting he'll be
guiding you you don't need to worry
if you'd like to receive that book the
number to call is 800-463-7297
actually that is the phone line to the
studio the number to call is
800-835-6747 pass today they've got them
right next to each other here on our
screen we need to
bring them further apart if you'd like
to receive the book as mentioned by
pastor doug determining the will of god
just call and ask for that and we'll be
happy to send it to you and again you
can go to the amazing factual website or
bible universe
and you can enroll in the free amazing
facts bible study school just a lot of
good information we also have just
thought of one other thing pastor we
have a program called the afco online
course it's actually a series of online
classes that a person can take that
brings them through
fundamental doctrines of the bible but
also how do you share your faith it's
great ministerial and mission training
yeah some good resources out there all
right we've got vanessa listening from
new york vanessa welcome to the program
hi
uh hi
hey guys um
get real close to your phone we can't we
can't hear you very well
i'm sorry okay can you hear me now yeah
and what's your question
okay so i've been struggling with
marijuana addiction and um
i quit
um but everyone in my house smokes
so it's been a little difficult do you
have any advice for me to
avoid temptation
yeah well like the last phone call i can
relate
because when i became a christian all of
my friends smoked pot in fact one of the
things i had to do when i became a
christian i became convicted to pull up
my pot plants now i didn't know any
better i pulled them up and gave them to
someone i probably should have thrown
them away
but i was i was still pretty young
and then all my friends that i hung out
with they kept smoking pot and offering
it to me and i was around it and i was
probably getting high off secondhand
smoke but i wouldn't smoke it anymore
but i finally i just started finding
other friends because the environment
just was not good so i don't know how
you can completely escape your
environment you may not be in a
situation where you could do that
because it could be your family
you can just ask them to respect your
decision
and when that behavior is happening you
just try and get into another room and
avoid that contact as much as possible
and there's a book we'd like to send you
it's called tips for resisting
temptation
because you know i was tempted when my
friends would pass the joint to
take another drag and go back into it
again and and it can be a struggle
praise god i didn't
but
it you know it's around you all the time
whether it's alcohol or pot
the number to call again is
800-835-6747 and the free book is called
tips for resisting temptation
we'd encourage anyone to call and ask
for that and just some practical good
bible encouragement on how we can resist
temptation if you're trying to live a
christian life you will have temptation
because the devil's not happy but you
can overcome in the strength of christ
uh next quarter that we have i think we
have time for one more we've got um
alamein listening in canada ella mae
welcome to the program
hi thank you for having me yes um or
listening to my question
second peter um one verse five says and
beside this giving all diligence after
your faith virtues and to virtue
knowledge and to knowledge temperance
and someone told me that
self-control or temperance is a gift
from god like um
like the holy spirit
it gives it gives people gift
as it thinks you know you should get a
gift
but i think self-control is more from a
person a person makes a decision and god
gives you the strength to
practice self-control
am i wrong if if i think of that is
there a bible verse that tells you that
self-control is a gift that you get from
god
well that's a great question uh and when
you look at the virtues that peter
itemizes here in
ii peter
chapter 1
and he says for this very reason giving
all diligence add to your faith virtue
to virtue knowledge to knowledge
self-control to self-control
perseverance the perseverance godliness
the godliness brotherly kindness and the
brotherly kindness love it's like
everything's building up to love well
these are fruits of the spirit but you
know you can actually
you can seek knowledge
uh when god gives you the gift of
knowledge you're not laying on your bed
and also he starts pouring knowledge
into your head
um i think what happens is
the lord gives you hunger for knowledge
and you feed your mind you feed your
soul the holy spirit will then bring
those things to remembrance i think when
you make an effort to resist some
temptation to exercise self-control
whether it's in something you do eat or
say
some people struggle with self-control
over their words the holy spirit will
then come to your aid so it's choosing
these things if
that's why peter mentions them he wants
us to choose
virtue self-control kindness and all
these different gifts and the spirit
then empowers us in performing those
things
you know just to add to that pastor
galatians chapter 5 is 22. it says but
the fruit of the spirit is love and joy
and peace and longsuffering and kindness
and goodness and faithfulness gentleness
and self-control against such there is
no law yeah so one of the evidences that
the holy spirit is working within the
life of a believer a person is
love joy peace and so on and
self-control that's one of those
identifying fruits of the holy spirit
it's important for christians to be able
to have that i mean it's
nothing will hinder your witness if
somebody loses their temper or can't
control themselves yeah it's not a good
witness
absolutely so appreciate that almay
hopefully that helps a little bit and um
i want to tell our friends who are
listening right now we don't have time
to take another question
uh live on the air but what we do is we
come back after a brief break and we end
up doing some rapid fire bible questions
now i it always takes a little
explaining but we broadcast amazing
facts bible answers live on hundreds of
stations around the country one of the
main stations is satellite and is all
over the north america on satellite
their clock timing is a little different
than the clock on these other land base
stations so we will be signing off with
our friends that are driving down the
road and listening on a cirrus xm
satellite we're usually on 131 during
this time i don't know if they do reruns
but then after that we're going to come
back don't go away those of you who are
on the other stations we're going to
come back and we're going to do rapid
fire internet questions that have come
in god bless i'll be right back
[Music]
stay tuned bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
hello friends welcome back to bible
answers live for those of you who stayed
by we're going to be looking at some uh
bible questions that came in from our
listeners if you would like to post a
bible question or email us a bible
question you can do so by simply
emailing bal questions at
amazingfacts.org
you can also type them if you're
watching on social media you can type
them in the comment section all right
pastor we've got some great questions
that are coming first one that we have
is in mark chapter 9 what does jesus
mean when he said that there are some
standing here who will not taste death
until they see the kingdom of god
yeah the key is what happens right after
he makes that statement you'll find that
in not only mark chapter 9 you'll find
it in matthew and you'll also find it in
luke
and immediately after he makes this
cryptic statement some of you standing
here will not taste of death until you
see the kingdom of god come with power
it says after six days he took them up
to this tall mountain and he was
transfigured before them and moses
appears and elijah appears and the voice
of god speaks and says this is my
beloved son and the disciples are
cowering
they got a miniature picture of the
second coming they saw christ in his
glory on the right hand of power
and they spoke to moses who represents
those who died and are resurrected and
they saw elijah there who represents
those who died and are translated the
whole thing was a microcosm of the
second coming the statement of jesus was
introducing what was about to happen
and
basically telling us we need a
mountaintop experience to prepare for
the cross and what's coming okay next
question that we have what is the
significance of palm sunday
yeah now
there are of course
millions of catholic people around the
world that celebrate palm sunday that's
because it when jesus had the triumphal
entry they would wave palms before him
and it's talking about the weak
immediately prior to the crucifixion and
so they've made a festival or a holiday
out of that there's no command in the
bible to do that but that's the reason
that our catholic friends have picked
that day
what was jesus doing after he ascended
to heaven to be with the father
well he the bible says he ever lives and
this in hebrews he ever lives to make
intercession for us
and so he is our high priest
and so he's there now he's in the holy
of holies before the father
interceding for us
uh he's our advocate
next question that we have um
is there more than one passover spoken
of in the bible
well passover was an annual feast and so
there several times they celebrated
passover but it only came once a year
and of course jesus during the last
supper was celebrating passover with the
disciples that's probably all we're
going to get to tonight pastor ross we
want to thank our friends for joining us
on bible answers live and we look
forward to studying god's word with you
again next week
[Music]
you